do you um do you to you
did you see those Mexican aliens
what do you mean
you didn't see him I have no idea what
you're talking about Mexico found the
aliens
Oh I thought you're saying Mexicans were
aliens no look at it right here let me
see
[Music]
Evolution posterior
Is that real yeah they're a size nine
and a half they're little dude yeah
they're a little dude
they did like an unbox aliens or Chinese
like it's a Marcus Brownlee video
yeah bro first of all why does that one
have asked best of Stewie I know but
they're little and they have little
Asian eyes and he's doing this
I'm not saying yeah
it looked like a Chinese dude who was
using a straw
and he got hit by a nuclear attack yeah
yeah go back to it whoa dude that's
crazy so that they found it huh yeah
they found two aliens dude and they
presented them
I love how there's like dirt around it
yeah
wow and one of them had eggs in it too
they said no yeah
dude I mean there we go dude do we have
any more information about it but come
on good that guy looks like
yeah it looked like he was raised
face first in a in a tuna can yeah
what's wrong with him I know yeah wow
dude wow look at the little nostril
that's cute though oh I think I wish
aliens looked like that oh a lot of
chicks I'm sure have already been in
this aliens DMS for sure yeah yeah
did they show the dick I have to know
the Dig uh I mean I bet it's pretty
similar
to what to Chinese people
I I don't know
but yeah wow what a cutie and that looks
like a government thing was that like on
like Mexican it was a Mexican government
yeah they had like a government like oh
yeah zoom in that I want to see that's
the whole body let me see
no dick look ooh someday it could be a
woman get in closer what do you mean
there's a little pile of something yeah
yeah God they're so cute huh yeah why
have people been putting cigarettes out
on him though
yeah yeah that's crazy dude look at the
posture too good posture I think
unbelievable yeah yeah it's just so like
like dude they can't break dance
I'll tell you that right now imagine
them dude
you know what I mean it's more of a mock
around Macarena it's something yeah yeah
that's a Cupid Shuffle maybe yeah yeah
wow I I man that's so interesting it's
so interesting dude